we have started with five co-founders
now we are a team of 200 plus people
unbelievable the interactive fact is
Michael we are both trapped completely
bootstraps wow
we have not raised a single money
and uh the kind of
uh Vision which we have and the from the
background which we came uh taking this
Vision I had is not at all easy or
possible for
anyone I would say welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today I am with zaiba Sarang the
co-founder at ifink Logistics an AI
based multi-carrier shipping platform
we're gonna hear her entrepreneurial
Story the way that they brought this
idea together from a pretty
multisciplinary team built with
entrepreneurship mindset Logistics
background and Engineering background so
welcome zaiba
foreign
behind I think Logistics looking at
selling shipping tracking you know
everything having to do with Logistics
in a world where e-commerce is taking
over everything and the consumer
behavior is drastically shifting over it
and and so
um yeah so really um what I'm excited to
understand you know from your stories
both who you are what I think Logistics
is all about and uh go ahead tell me
tell me a little bit great so I'll start
with the Journey of I think logistic so
we have started this company in 2017 uh
with five co-founders with a vision to
help our e-commerce sellers or d2c
Brands to have optimized not just sick
e-commerce Solutions available with them
and uh in the in terms of a dedicated or
a single dashboard so I think logistic
we are an AI based multi-carrier
shipping platform so it's like a single
and simple dashboard all tool to
automate eCommerce seller shippingly so
like it's a platform where one side we
have all the Top Logistic Partners
associated with us like that every Blue
Dart and ecomix well these are the
national Indian logistic Partners we
have and on the other side we have the
d2t brands what selling products from uh
started from their own small how to
being a Enterprise customer for now so
what we do so we have our recommendation
engine which is an AI based so through
our recommendation engine we help the
e-commerce sellers to select the best
logistic Partners available on that
specific steel code because Michael you
uh you know India is geographically
divided in multiple States multiple PIN
codes and there has been a different uh
the operational constraint by each and
every logistic Partners have their own
course strength if in terms of
delivering in specific state or in
specific pin code so we help them to
identify identify the sellers which pin
code is serviceable well by which
Partners like entire operations is done
by or managed by the logistic Partners
which we are opting for them it's like
we are a solution provider we are an
enabler where we just uh marry or we
just solicitate these two players who
have a dedicated or required solution
for their entire Logistics so this is
what we do in a nutshell if we talk
about our strength so as an organization
icing logistic where our strength is uh
technology Tech part without platform
which we have developed we are the only
aggregator I would say or we are the
only service provider in terms of this
aggregation where we hold a patient test
technology
so we have a patented ndr technology
Michael I'll just get into more uh
detail if you want yeah please yeah okay
so uh in India people still prefer to
have a cod as that Preferred Choice of
option while being doing a payment for
any shipment right so because it's a Cod
options or payment there are n number of
challenges involved in getting the
shipments delivered to the end consumer
they happen by by this this happens with
the mistake of the logistic partner or
the delivery boys and this also happened
it's communication gap between the
customer and the logistic team so what
we have done we have created this
patented ndr tool ndr stands for
non-delivery report which help the
sellers to have a maximum successful
deliveries of their shipments so we do
multiple actions on different statuses
of the shiftness and we make sure if a
customer or buyer is interested to take
the shipment the shipment should get
delivered to them
if the logistic partner is not able to
deliver because of XYZ reasons or
challenges we help them to resolve it
through our Tech part
so we are known for helping the sellers
to increase the delivery performance or
to have a maximum successful delivery so
that they their revenue can increase or
they will be able to make a profit out
of the business which they are running
interesting so tell me make it clear to
you Michael yeah no no definitely take
me back a little bit to the you know to
how you even entered the space you know
what what was it about logistics from
your own personal sort of career that
led you to this inspiration or to even
getting excited about this problem space
very interesting story Michael I would I
will share with you so uh prior to I
think Logistics
after graduating from computer science
me and my other co-founder vipul and
Bharat
we founded our technology company by the
name of depaser infotech where we were
providing a Solutions or services to
different brands technological solutions
like we were creating bespoke softwares
for them taking the requirement and
getting it delivered plus we also worked
three few e-commerce websites as well
and we have identified this challenge
what they were facing they were not able
to get a dedic a platform where they
will get a required solution for their
shipping needs they have to coordinate
the e-commerce sellers had to coordinate
multiple partners plus if they are just
starting the business they were not
getting a proper support and services
from the logistic partners because of
their lower volume so they were just
neglecting these players those the
partners or the website folder who are
just starting their e-commerce Journey
they were not getting a support or
Confidence from the logistic parts so he
identified this one Challenge and
another challenge was the delivery
performance they were getting so many
rtos in fact we also ran our own
e-commerce website and we had to shut
down that because of uh the logistic
challenges we personally faced right
interesting
and after that my another two
co-founders parisha Nicole who are also
our friend they both came from a
logistic background so in fact for it
was an X Amazon so he worked for Amazon
middle mind and their housing solution
and same with Nikola so he also holds a
logistic experience so five of us we
decided like three of us from the
technology background found this
Challenge on the other side these two
people are from logistic background
understood how the logistic Works
entirely and then together we marry and
created this entire uh platform for the
tennis and back 2017 the e-commerce
industry has started growing and there
were there has been actual demand for
this kind of solution I would say and or
a platform
mm-hmm interesting to so how does this
actually work you know more tangibly on
on the obviously there's different
stakeholders here that have to you you
have to partner with and to gain their
trust tell me a little bit about these
different stakeholders that you're that
you're working with and and how your
what sort of the
I guess the the mutual been
beneficiaries of you know of both
parties here
I'll give you a simple example of uber
so Uber or Airbnb I would say
they don't hold any of the asset they
hold any or they don't hold any
operational uh procedure altogether they
are a platform so similarly I think
Logistics we are also a platform one
side we have the logistic partner where
one side Uber has all the drivers
and on the other side there are there
are passengers of uber who want to take
a ride so Uber as a platform they
connect together as a passenger they get
right from a specific uh from their
location and driver gets uh required
flips on daily basis similarly this
platform which we have created one side
we have all the logistic partners who
are based on operating fan India likes
delivery Blue Dart Ecom expressvs
Etc these are the logistic Partners
which we have and other sites these uh
we have the e-commerce sellers or d2c
band we through Tech we just let them
know on this pin code if you are getting
one order this pin code is served by all
the partners but logistic partner one
have performed well in terms of their
successful delivery
so you can get those Partners you can
choose them as your preferred partners
and this is what a e-commerce sellers
get a benefit out of it like they don't
have to communicate with multiple
partners in our platform if they are
coming they will be getting all the
partners listed under one umbrella
and through the recommendation engine
which partner should get assigned that's
we logically designed we have designed
it and they get assigned to them and the
operational part is taken care by the
Legislative company and the e-commerce
sellers they don't have to communicate
with multiple stakeholders in terms of
multiple logistic partner there will be
a single platform they don't have to do
multiple Tech integration I would say
it's a single platform single dashboard
where they can opt for all the partners
which we have listed and which are
currently able to serve pan India
they don't have to go another parting
they don't have to find and go look out
for another partner altogether
and this is what we do there is will be
a single Billing System they don't have
to get multiple bills from the multiple
partners there will be single billing
single uh communication single platform
to be precise this is what we do and for
the e-commerce sellers or d2c brand and
if we talk about the logistic Partners
what's benefit they are get getting out
of it like they don't have to serve the
small small players we are giving them a
bulk uh order we would say
we have to communicate with us they also
don't have to communicate with small
small players who does around five
orders 10 order a day
sure but our volume is around 25 to 30
000 shipments in a day and we have a
certain holding in terms of
communication with them certain support
which we get uh students yeah well what
are the biggest challenges here in a
space like this or the biggest
challenges that you expect to that
you're either meeting already or that
you expect to meet through and you know
through I think Logistics
the challenges in terms of your talking
about our business or challenges in
terms of
I mean yeah I mean as you're building I
think Logistics you know what what are
the most difficult things in the way of
of you growing this company into the
vision that you see for it I mean what
what is sort of the well not not
challenges but what are the the more
difficult stages that you're going to
have to go through do you think or the
more interesting problems you're going
to have to to tackle in order to grow I
think Logistics into what you want it to
be
any interesting challenges that you
think
so initially when we had started uh
honestly we we do had a logistic
experience like two of the co-founders
we do have a tech
experience but the uh that wasn't some
certain uh
procedure or certain I would say hacks
which we were not
aware of
where we can just you know just tweak
this thing and get benefit out of it as
a company for the seller and for the
logistic partner initially when we have
this recently started we were not aware
and we failed uh two three times
that in fact we we Face the challenge
where uh there was few standards uh it
was a post-paid model for them like
after a month we we were taking bill
payment from them so few sellers just
ran away with the money
to be to be to be discussed but it
happened with us when we had recently
started it was a huge lacks of money
which we just launched with the seller
but the best part which we had is we had
a good relationship with our logistic
companies from the starting point also
without service provider we personally
went to their head office we met the
head or TFO of those companies we
discussed this problem with them and we
told like we are stuck in this situation
and currently we don't have this money
to pay to your bill so will you be able
to allow us some time
right uh
they trusted us and we are really
grateful to the partners or the service
providers which we are working with them
right now they literally trusted us and
they gave or dead they gave a Indian
timeline to you know get the new uh paid
so that was the initial challenge Big
Challenge I would say if they would have
not supported I believe that time he
might have to shut down I think wow
it was a first year only it was fourth
year only yeah
looking into the future
how how what do you think what do you
think will be you know maybe even on the
question of growth and scale either on
the technological front on the logistics
Partnerships front what are the most
interesting things you're going to
you're going to be facing as you're
going to grow this business
so we all know how e-commerce industry
is growing and we literally see the
demand for domestic and international
shipping as well
so as an I think logistic along with
domestic we are also expanding ourselves
to International as well
so we have recently started our
International offerings to countries
like USA Australia Canada interesting
yeah so where uh it is it is not an
aggregation model itself it's a product
stitching where the we will be facing or
we will be the one who will be uh taking
the shipping shipments from those step
to delivering to the those countries
again it it doesn't include any
operational
operation uh facilities by icing
Logistics it will be done by the
partners only we will be only stitching
the product yeah yeah for sure and what
made you decide that it's the right time
for in the company's perspective to
transition and to expand out of India
I'm sure that besides you know even
though there's the technology you know
maybe able to service different things
but you know there's different cultures
different partnership personas different
expectations what what made you make
this make this jump
very interesting Michael so what
happened when we were in the Kobe
situation uh 2022 20 uh when koi just
hits the globe or world uh we have
identified like we have to uh expand
ourselves to multi not we should not be
defocus ourselves but we also have to
expand our services to different
countries also along with different
products as well
and while faced world was facing uh
covet situation we have identified this
there were few sellers who were along
with shipping domestic they were also
shipping internationally as well
and we found
in e-commerce as of now and the main
challenge is the biggest challenge which
we have identified and we wanted to fall
through our international shipping
Services is there is none of the sellers
none of the service provider as of now
who are main focus on e-commerce seller
shipping groundwater shipping
so we do have FedEx we do have DHL we do
have India fourth Etc but they are not
able to capture or Focus challenges who
are specific to e-commerce Center they
are more into export they are more into
budget shipping
and we are only and majorly focusing on
e-commerce sellers need so like they
need a smaller weight slabs as well so
like if we talk about DHL FedEx if you
want to ship a product which is 200
Grand you have to pay the amount of 500
grams only
they don't have a smaller slabs with
them so we have introduced a smaller
slab which starts from 50 Grand
sometimes ground for a small jewelry
seller we just want to ship earrings or
ring to from India to uh USA from Jaipur
to USA they need this kind of services
plus they need a dedicated Tech where
integration with those uh marketplaces
like Amazon eBay
Etsy
right so the these were the challenges
plus unified tracking there was no
tracking available as such by those
other stores so we had identify all
those things and accumulated and combine
this thing and providing the services to
International sellers fantastic what are
you most excited by in this journey for
you in this company
joining the people growing together
co-founders now we are a team of 200
plus people unbelievable the interactive
fact is Michael we are both trapped
completely bootstraps wow
we have not raised a single money
and uh the kind of
Vision which we have and the from the
background which we came uh taking this
Vision I had is not at all easy or
possible for
anyone I would say
incredible really very very exciting uh
Journey all together really
each day comes up with a new challenge
each day comes up with new solution and
it always gives her the push to be a
better person to be a better
organization altogether
incredible that's um really really
fascinating and congratulations on on
such a such incredible Milestones
um 200 people with trap scaling globally
International it sounds like you you
have a deep understanding of the needs
of the the Integrations and the space
and everything that's been happening so
really um
it's been it's been a really really fun
listening to sort of your your
understanding and and the founding
journey and what and almost closing the
company and so I'm looking forward to
continuing following from the side and
sharing from the side and following and
so Zava thank you very very much for all
the help and the support and for the
show and for your presence here and and
I look forward to continuing following I
think Logistics from the side and
cheering so thank you very much thank
you so much Michael thank you for being
me here thank you it's a little bit
better
foreign
[Music]